Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
for
what?
Continuing
in the 210th chapter therein authored by
under the chapter title
the chapter regarding the merits and
virtues of the day of Jum the obligation
of Jum
and bathe bathing for the occasion of
the day of a jum. also wearing perfume
or wearing some kind of this is for men
in public only as opposed to females and
going as early as possible to the jum.
Also
another part of this chapter will be the
merits of making dua specifically on the
day of J
and making exceptional amounts of
salah upon the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
This chapter will also address
the time of acceptance which is on every
day of Jum when a person's dua will
be accepted
and
the
virtue
and that it is you know something that
is highly recommended
that a person
remember Allah in copious amounts after
the prayer of J.
[Silence]
forch.
This narration that he mentions is a
narration on the authority of and also
on the authority of Omar
which states that they heard the
messenger of Allah
saying on his member once
that a people will for will stop and
cease foregoing
attendance of alum
lest Allah stamp and seal their hearts
and they end up being of those who are
those who are put into a spiritual
slumber and unawareness.
So here we have a narration
in which Abu and Omar
they mention
that they heard the messenger of Allah
say on the
why is this detail important
and its
is supposed to be about The core
principles of Islam.
This is the essence of Juma. Juma is not
supposed to be a class, a detailed
lecture. It is not supposed to be on
peripheral issues or minutia.
Jum is supposed to be on the core
tenants of Islam and the core virtues of
Islam. Straying from that
is to stray from the way of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam and to stray from
the purpose
that alum was obligated for everyone to
attend.
And so what is supposed to be on the day
of jum what is the supposed to speak
about? Should the khib speak about
minutia, details, nuances,
particular issues that are
differences of opinion should he speak
about? No, none of these things are what
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam would
address in his in J
is a very
fundamental rudimentary. It's a very
macro issue
meaning that we speak about the core
tenants and principles of Islam and it
is supposed to be simple and it is the
most important things that every Muslim
needs to know and hear and be reminded
of. This is what Ju is for. This is what
it is about.
When we stray from that, we blunt this
instrument that is the of J. We take
away its intended purpose.
And so
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam when he
mentions something on the member,
it's usually because it's the J that
he's giving. because he would usually
use the meim to
give announcements or to give the of J.
So when a companion tells us he was on
the member when he said this, we
understand that this is one of the core
principles of Islam. This is not an
issue of a difference of opinion or some
companions can know it and others can be
ignorant of it. This is something that
should be common knowledge amongst the
Muslims. It is of vital importance to
every Muslim to know whatever he says on
the members saiam.
It wasn't in a personal gathering. It
wasn't in his home. It wasn't around a
campfire. It wasn't while he was
traveling. It was on the member when the
most ears are listening. And so this
tells us that this principle of
attending Jum is one of the core
principles of Islam that is common
knowledge amongst the Muslim. It is not
an issue of debate at all.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
not only says this on the member but he
says it
as a warning.
He warns.
He says
those who forego attendance of Jumra
will cease doing so
or Allah will seal their hearts and they
will slip into a spiritual slumber, a
spiritual psychosis,
a spiritual sleep or a spiritual
delusion in which they cannot see their
way out of anymore. They will not even
know that they are sleeping to even try
to wake themselves up. This is the
danger of that. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has told us that those whom he
seals their ears and their eyes and
seals their hearts, they are the ones
who are asleep.
They are the ones who are
and so what happens when Allah seals a
person's heart
that means that they cannot benefit from
that which they hear they cannot benefit
from that which they see in any
meaningful or lasting way and the light
and truth can no longer penetrate their
hearts.
And so a person will be asleep and think
that they're awake. They will be
dreaming but they think that they are
awake and they're experiencing reality.
Their way of seeing the world will
become delusional. They're not seeing it
it as it is anymore. This is the danger
of foregoing the of J upon who? upon
those whom meet the criteria of J. Who
is obligated to attend J? Al Muslim
al-
Mim
[Silence]
that who is jum obligatory upon the
Muslim
who is sane who is of age who is past
the age of puberty who is a resident
who is healthy
and who is not a slave. Slaves are not
obligated to attend Jama. Some scholars
exempt those who are traveling.
Meaning that when you are traveling, you
don't have to have a jum in your
caravan. But if a person is traveling in
a land and they hear the dua, the aan of
jum, do they have to attend? Difference
of opinion amongst the scholars.
However, it would tend towards the
generality of the statement of Allah.
That's
[Silence]
alhamdulillah.